bonjour et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur arte france est ce que ces
résultats vous surprennent ou bien
était-il attendu oui et non parce que
ces résultats ils sont fait mentir les
enquêtes d'opinion qui donnait plus de
sièges à des partis traditionnels mais a
néanmoins les citoyens chiliens ont
voulu montrer qu'il voulait vraiment
arrêter avec cette politique cette
classe politique et sans envoyer un
message très fort et très déterminés
pour changer changer la constitution
donc de ce côté et son était vraiment on
est avec ce qu'il voulait ce qu'ils
avaient manifesté dans le premier
référendum
alors les grands vainqueurs de ce
scrutin ce sont les partis de gauche et
les indépendants et les candidats
indépendants quels sont les projets des
uns et des autres dans la rédaction de
la nouvelle constitution chilienne
bon d'abord les projets c'est ça va vous
paraître peut-être insolite mais la
phrase la plus utilisée pour les
chiliens c'est de retrouver la dignité
parce que la constitution est une
constitution néolibérale à outrance qui
a été imposé pour la par la dictature du
général pinochet donc des services comme
l'éducation la santé la retraite ont été
données au marché privé
est ce que veulent les gens les chiliens
aujourd'hui c'est retrouver ses limites
et à travers un pays une constitution
qui protège certaines choses comment
comme la santé l'éducation les retraites
mais aussi l'écologie est aussi certains
sujets importants
comment les féminismes les minorités
sexuelles où les minorités
indigène qu'ils vont participer aussi
dans l'écriture de cette cantine
constitution et alors est ce que les
indépendants et les partis de gauche
vous semble pouvoir s'entendre et
collaboré sur le long terme il faut
savoir que c'est les femmes dépendantes
qui ont eu la majorité des sièges pour
écrire la constitution après il ya la
gauche alternative qui peut s'entendre
très bien avec les indépendants et la
gauche traditionnelle qui pourra
peut-être pathé a essayé d amoindrir
certaines lois
donc c'est très faisable que certains
loi soit inscrit dans la constitution et
qui assure certaines droit qui en avait
perdu pendant la dictature
dans ce contexte quel est l'avenir de la
droite conservatrice chilienne quelle
est la marge de manoeuvre de de
sebastian pinera
bon aujourd'hui et l'ac ont souffert un
grand rêveur avec sept votes qu'ils
attendaient pas ils
et il croyait vraiment qu'avec la façon
de botter ils pourront obtenir un tiers
des votes
et avec ça pour voir influencé
l'écriture de la nouvelle constitution
néanmoins aujourd'hui là autant la
droite comme tous les partis
traditionnels c'est sont en train de
repenser la façon dont ils doivent faire
la politique parce qu'ils sont vu
qu'elle est citoyens chiliens ne veulent
plus de ce genre de classe politique et
ne veulent plus d'un certain népotisme
en politique et donc ils doivent
repenser tout la façon de s'adresser aux
citoyens chien que ils se sont montrés
capables d d'échanger une constitution
qui a été imposé pour la par la
dictature
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à notre invitation sur rt
france à gabriella bravo je rappelle que
vous êtes jourdain journaliste chilienne
correspondante à paris